All right. Okay. So, I'm going to try to
keep you all engaged for the next 20
minutes. I know it's been a long day,
but um in this session, I'm going to be
talking about exploring the AI
automation boundary for threat hunting.
My name is Arthy Nagarajin. I am a
software engineer at Data Dog. I work
closely with internal threat
intelligence and detection teams to
productionize and scale up their
security processes.
Over the past six to nine months, we've
been developing an AI powered threat
hunting tool called the hunting copilot.
I'll share the lessons we learned along
the way and how our understanding of the
automation boundary for AI in threat
hunting evolved through real world use.
Our goal is to equip our interning
internal threat hunting teams with tools
to accelerate their hunts. As a
developer, there are two questions I
needed to answer. What should we
automate and how should we automate it?
Threat hunting is reminiscent of trying
to find a needle in a haststack. A
magnitude of data that looks normal to
the untrained eye, but the attack is
written in between the lines. A data dog
hunter searched through a massive volume
of logs from many different sources with
varying schemas. It's really tedious to
figure out which queries will surface
the antenna data. And these queries are
really important because they eventually
become detection rules.
That's why we mainly decided to automate
query generation. Since log data is
represented as text, it seemed like an
obvious use case for LLMs.
This was our first question. Are modern
LLMs good at threat hunting out of the
box? If this is true, my job would be
super easy. And we started really
simple. We used OpenAI's GPT4.1 model in
a single agent, equipped it with web
search capabilities and the AWS
knowledge MCP for searching cloud trail
schema documentation.
In the system prompt, we linked the data
dog syntax documentation and provided
some threat hunting hypothesis to query
examples and just said, "Hey, you're a
threat hunting agent. Do your thing."
The results were okay. Given a broad
threat hunting prompt, the agent would
generate several specific hypotheses
with corresponding data dog lucine
queries. Response time was really fast,
an average of 5 seconds. However, syntax
error rate was quite high at 25%. Our
hunters complained about the aggressive
hypothesis production and the frequently
misnamed fields and irrelevant values.
They also wanted the agent to
automatically rule out some false
positives. For instance, if the surface
logs are associated with a known testing
account, it should interpret that.
In summary, the major failures of our
first iteration were low syntax
accuracy, low semantic accuracy. So this
means that the query does not surface
the intended data because the fields are
wrong. I'm going to be talking about
schema and saying the word schema like a
thousand times in this talk. But this is
really the crux of our work on this
tool.
It also struggled with low relevance. So
it wasn't using the data to drive
conclusions and we attributed a lot of
this to ineffective tool usage. It was
just ignoring whatever tools we provided
it.
We concluded that LLMs are bad at threat
hunting and we had to go back to the
basics and understand what their
capabilities actually were. LLMs are
good at
synthesis, pattern matching and
translation. We needed to focus on
reducing threat hunting into problems of
these categories.
Before I get into the second iteration
of the hunting co-pilot, I have to
address the obvious obstacle in the AI
threat hunting space, and that's data.
Let's start with the nature of the log
data we're quering. At Data Dog, we have
large volumes of telemetry with look
back periods of up to 450 days. And
these logs are composed of faceted
fields, which are indexed and easy to
filter on, and many unfaceted fields.
These are raw attributes that can be
searched, but they aren't indexed. And
this is what makes capturing the full
schema of a source or index in a small
number of tokens very challenging. It's
even harder to understand what kinds of
values exist for each field without
actually querying the data.
We also have customizable ingestion
pipelines that increase automation
complexity. And finally, threat hunting
in general is hard to capture concretely
because the success criteria is very
ambiguous. The inputs, outputs, and
methods used differ greatly from hunt to
hunt and hunter to hunter.
Fundamentally, this means we don't have
a reliable ground truth readily
available, neither for query generation
nor for overall threat hunting.
We thought about fine-tuning our agent
before anyone asks. And the solution
only makes sense if you have access to
good threat hunting data. By good data,
I mean data that is representative,
well-labeled, and in abundance. We did
not already have a well-curated corpus
of past threat hunts with consistent
inputs and outputs labeled labeled in a
way that can apply to unseen hunts.
Given the amount of time and resources
it would have taken to produce this and
the fact that we needed to deliver
results quickly, we decided to stick to
advanced prompt engineering techniques.
Finetuning was just too high risk and
high effort with expected low return.
This is the point in our journey where
we had to reframe the problem. Our
hunters needed this agent to be accurate
and useful. After syntax accuracy,
semantic accuracy was the top weakness.
And in other words, queries that were
syntactically valid were still answering
the wrong question.
So we reframed the problem around field
discovery. We sat down with our threat
hunters and asked them to walk us
through how they analyze logs in a hunt.
We found that their process was
fortunately repeatable. It's a mix of
informed guessing, sampling, and
iterative refinement. They start with an
initial hypothesis and broad queries.
They dive into the raw logs and inspect
sample values. Then they tweak their
query and repeat this process until they
find something valuable.
We call this process log schema
exploration.
Instead of relying on documentation as a
source of truth, the schema should be
derived directly from the data.
We shifted the boundary more towards AI
with automated data analysis. So use the
data to drive conclusions and this would
address the hunter's request to rule out
some false positives as well.
There were several several sub
iterations that led to V2, but the core
shift was towards a multi-agent
framework. We introduced reasoning
models such as GPT 5.1 and implemented
an orchestrator expert framework. We
also added the data dog MCP server and
this allowed the agent to execute the
queries it generated and then validate
them against real logs. One of the most
valuable features of this MCP is that it
returns concise corrections when
something is wrong and that was the key
to improving syntax accuracy.
Lastly, we tightened the system prompt
and defined iterative query refinement
behaviors as well as stop conditions.
And we noticed that the agent struggled
with tricky syntax like negation or JSON
policy document formatting which our
threat hunters love to search on and
wildcard placement. So we provided more
concrete construction rules in this case
for that.
This is an overview of the architecture.
We have the orchestrator. It's handling
the investigation flow maintaining the
overall hunt context. It then gathers
source documentation from expert sub
aents such as for AWS cloud trail or GCP
audit logs. It then calls the data dog
agent and it's essentially a wrapper for
the data dog MCP. It generates and
iteratively refineses queries based on
the data. We noticed that queries that
return zero results were most likely
semantically incorrect. So we just
biased the agent towards generating logs
results. Our stop conditions were both
quantitative. So cap the number of
iterations at five and subjective. If
you find logs and can reach a
conclusion, stop iterating.
This divide and conquer approach reduced
overall context load um context overload
and made each step more controlled and
precise.
With this architecture, we noticed a
huge improvement in syntax accuracy by
17% and slightly better semantic
accuracy, but tool usage increased. All
this, however, was at the cost of
response speed. We went from an average
of 5 seconds per response to 6 minutes.
Some edge cases taking 30 minutes to an
hour. Our you our users were not happy
with this response time and semantic
accuracy was still hindered by
persistent hallucination. This was
because query executions often timed out
or the results were truncated. Sampling
log data was just too computationally
exhaustive to be handled by the agent
alone.
We learned a lot about the trade-offs of
multi- aent frameworks and powerful MCP
tools with V2 and it all comes down to
context. This principle hasn't changed.
Threat hunting workflows overload
context. If you manage the context well,
you'll see results improve.
The core lessons from V2 were that we
should use reasoning sparingly. It was
way too slow for production use cases.
And if you use it, you should provide
reasoning transparency to the user.
Multi-agent frameworks are an excellent
way to manage context. So the
orchestrator is building context over
the course of a hunt, but each expert
agent, it starts fresh every time it's
called. Based on how you conquer and
divide these sub agents can become
excellent at their specific task, and
you save context space for the overall
hunt.
However, delegation introduces its own
cost. Every handoff adds latency and
Asian coordination will increase
complexity.
A quick note on chaining. We noticed
that chains of length over three were
subject to getting stuck downstream,
especially if there was some looping,
and that's what we had with the
iterative refinement in the data dog
agent.
So, we try to keep our architecture at
three layers or less.
Tools are crucial, but they need to be
concise and informative. We designed
tools to return short suggestions to
take the burden of correction off of the
agent. And we always specified a concise
list of of allowed tools for MTP servers
that expose many. The system prompt
should describe which tool should be
called at which step.
And I am aware of the very fickle nature
of making bold claims on what AI can and
cannot do. I did see the talks yesterday
especially anthropic Nicholas um opus
4.5 and 4.6 were released quite
recently. So, as these LLMs get more
powerful and the context window
increases, you can simplify your
architecture while keeping
hallucinations low. But I'd argue that
right now for threat hunting,
multi-agent frameworks are still
necessary for the best results.
Achieving high query syntax accuracy was
pretty easy, but semantic accuracy is
really hard because of the high volume
and density of the data. There are four
fundamental approaches that we've been
exploring to manage this. So the first
is external documentation and AIS
basically you're trying to make an
educated guess on what the schema may
look like at data dog and in practice
this wasn't very representative of the
data log clustering and aggregations
they can really help cut down the logs
that need to be analyzed. However it's
very easy to misjudge which facets to
aggregate on and the agent usually
guesses wrong. the built-in clustering
within the data dog logs logs platform
if you've seen it. It's based on the
message body or status and that's not
always relevant to the hunts. Our
hunters love aggregating on super niche
facets and attributes. We could
pre-process with ingestion pipeline
data. So build an understanding of
schema statically. We gather all the
remappers and grock parsers from the
configuration pipeline and then we feed
that into the context. But it still
misses some information and it's
consuming a lot of context space and
it's also subject to change. So we still
need a more dynamic approach that would
be live sampling dynamically learn
schema from the data and again this is
computationally exhaustive. So we had to
shift the expectation of handling this
away from AI agents and towards the
tools.
Our solution is a sort of coordinated
dance amongst all of these options and
we fortify and tweak reliance on each
one based on the performance that we're
seeing.
Okay, evaluations a pretty painstaking
though undeniably important topic. The
data problem I mentioned earlier, it it
applies here. We do not have a
well-curated corpus of threat hunting
data for a traditional evaluation
system. Even when we generated that
data, we noticed that evaluation results
were not reflective of its performance
in unseen hats. These traditional
evaluation systems with inputs and
expected outputs, they just produced a
bunch of statistics and oftentimes they
showed high accuracy for certain tasks,
but our users disagreed. So passing
evaluations did not always correlate
with trust. A single number to capture
the performance can be quite misleading.
Like claiming that an agent is 95%
accurate, that could mean anything. and
it makes you think that it'll be
accurate 95% of the time in future
hunts. What matters is it's the data
rubrics and scoring mechanis mechanisms
behind the evaluation mechanism that
actually carries the truth. And so
there's this trade-off between the time
invested into a robust evaluation system
and developing the tool especially given
the size of our team. So we invested
time into other eval strategies.
Our
strategy was to prioritize trends,
comparative metrics, and human feedback
over static benchmark performance. We
conducted AB testing during our hunt
weeks. So, human versus machine. Some
hunters use the tool and others didn't.
And we compared their respective
results. We rely on a frequent and tight
user feedback loop and also collect data
as the hunters use the tool to figure
out when and how they choose to use it.
Because for us, usage corresponded to
success.
We pruned non-essential evaluation
metrics and distilled it down to a few
tasks that traditional benchmarking made
sense for like response speed or syntax
accuracy because we have like a data dog
syntax validation checker for semantic
accuracy. We're not just pinning an LLM
based judge against it like that would
be circular because we just I just
argued that LLMs aren't very skilled at
that. What we do instead is that we run
the agent on our test prompts and we
extract the unique queries and then we
run them to see the results. Um, and it
for the test cases that didn't have any
results, we would do a lot of manual
verification. And we did, you know, we
did add an LLM judge on that. But it's
kind of a combination of different
tactics as opposed to just what does LLM
base judge think um, off the bat.
All right. So, that was kind of the
preface and how we built it. And now I
want to walk through how our tool aided
our hunters in a recent ADS privilege
escalation, hunt week.
One of our hunters focused on an
escalation path with the AM create login
profile event. This is a pretty dense
slide, so I'll try to walk you through
it as best as I can. Starting on the
left, top left, you can see that the
agent generated a starting query and
automatically broaden the scope from 1
day to 7 days, then eventually 30 days.
Moving down, the agent identified six
distinct targets and correctly assumed
that they were associated with test
accounts. It identified the type of
password reset behav be behavior that
made some of these events suspicious
versus not.
I I had to redact some of this um
information, but funny enough, these
users were actually generated by one of
our security research teams um as test
threat actors. So, it was pretty cool
that our agent could identify them.
There's no incident, but um definitely
identifying suspicious behavior.
And then moving to the right or yes I
think my uh rights and lefts are
confused but um it then provided a
verdict of likely benign as well as next
steps for verifying them and potential
pivots. It named these are the users you
should reach out to and figure out if
they're actually authorized to have
these roles.
Our hunter also progressed it by asking
if there were subsequent console login
for the created users. So the agent
generated a new query and identified
that there wasn't any evidence of that
and it did it for all of the relevant
users that it found in a prior request.
So this was a pretty good success case
and I I think what also made it
successful is that there was a hunter
that was driving it with a very concrete
playbook. Um so the agent was doing a
lot of the searching and the data
analysis but um the hunt was kind of
defined or the playbook was defined by
the expert in this case.
Last thing I wanted to show is some of
our reasoning transparency. So basically
it's a little bit dense but these are
the requests that were sent to the sub
agent. So it called the AWS agent once
and the data dog agent numerous number
of times to really do that iterative
refinement. So it's both data dog agent
calling the data dog MCP a bunch of
times and the orchestrator agent calling
the data dog agent a bunch of times. So
there's two loops here.
We also ran an AB testing week um in the
same AWS privilege escalation hunt week.
Team A utilized the hunting co-pilot and
team B was a more experienced threat
hunter could not use the hunting
co-pilot, but they could use chat GPT.
It didn't make sense to cut out AI usage
entirely. We tracked live metrics for
the tool, but we also had them fill out
rubrics and questionnaires for
subjective scoring.
There were many hypotheses explored
during this week. So we reviewed the
results holistically and compared
similar hypotheses. This is because we
wanted to minimize testing disruption
for their hunts. Like these are actual
production hunts and they're expected to
deliver results from these. When we
compared the results of the two teams,
we found that the hunting co-pilot cut
the average query iteration time from 10
minutes to 5 minutes and the hunt
duration for each of these hypotheses
were about 60 minutes and the tool
helped save 25 of those minutes. We also
noticed that the response times all
remained under six minutes for this week
in particular.
When we looked at the subjective scores,
the tool succeeded in hypothesis
relevancy and context awareness. It
stayed on track and it used the data to
drive conclusions. However, on more
complex hypotheses where a lot of data
needed to be analyzed, it struggled with
signal to noise control. The data volume
was just too high and it wasn't able to
automatically garner insights from the
surface logs because there was a lot of
truncation happening. So there's still
room for improvement and it helped us
decide which solutions of the four I was
talking about to prioritize for semantic
accuracy.
Also, if you're curious, the hunt week
produced um two new cloud detection
rules and uncovered zero incidents.
We garnered a deeper understanding of
the automation boundary and how we can
help our hunters. Currently, our
automation boundary is three-fold. In
addition to query generation and data
analysis, our hunters also wanted the
agent to pull in different sources and
pivot on these hypotheses.
More precisely, when we saw reduced
performance, we refocused AI usage on
the components that actually map to its
strengths like summarization and
synthesis. It was optimal for our team
to let the threat hunters drive the
hunt, focus on automating field
discovery with high accuracy, and
provide a convenient single platform to
query all telemetry sources with one
language, which in this case was
English.
Thank you so much. Um, I have a link to
the public version of the slides in my
LinkedIn in the corner. Um, thanks again
for listening and let me know if you
have any questions.
questions.
>> Very good. Thank you.
for the LLM judges you talked about, did
you use different LLM providers like
different uh foundation models or
different local models? And um which
models were the most uh if you did,
which models were in the most agreement
with a human judge or how often did they
kind of differ in their opinion of of
the judging?
>> Yeah, that's a good question. We we
didn't do a very thorough analysis of
how different models and different
providers gave different results
especially for evaluation. I think we
just didn't invest that much time. What
we did compare was reasoning versus
non-reasoning. And so for the judge
honestly we had to prioritize speed in
that case. So we opted we didn't opt for
reasoning because we didn't really
noticed a huge improvement in accuracy
or how well it thought like similar to a
human. So we were prioritizing speed in
that case and more manual verification.
So I guess the short answer is we didn't
do a thorough analysis there. Um but uh
we did notice a huge difference between
reasoning and non-reasoning models.
>> Um did you guys ever like went into like
some sort of like a confidence score?
Um, the reason I mentioned that is I
think Salesforce guys did a presentation
about anomaly detection and whatnot and
they would annotate like some sort of
like a confidence score like a low,
medium or high. I don't know if you guys
thought about that or looked into it.
>> Uh, so confidence score on what the
agent is producing.
Yeah, I I think we didn't generate like
a confidence score meaning like how
confident the agent is in this answer
because a lot of it it was it tended to
be quite confident because we were
giving it like a promptive you are to
generate very accurate data dog lucine
queries and it would think that it was
generating accurate lucine queries and
similarly when we tried to judge it the
judge was like this is 100% correct. it
it was a very circular. So, um that's
not something we focused on because it
wasn't reflective of what how it
actually performed with our users.
>> Yeah. Great.
>> All right. Thank you very much.